I've always had a fitness goal of  running a marathon I just do it because  I'm a good runner and it's really easy  to me so I don't just need to sign up  for one I guess so I want to run a  marathon but I don't have to do it this  year so I do before I die it's like a  bucket list thing but for 2018 fitness  goals I mean the thing is is I'm I'm not  like super attached to increasing my one  rep max on my Olympic lifts or anything  it's not like I need to you know  clean-and-jerk 150 this year to feel  like I I did something I think for me  the goals are really just to continue to  make my body more healthy and to honor  it I think sometimes I actually get it  caught in a circle of overtraining where  I just I just do too much and I don't  rest enough so listening to my body for  when I need to take breaks is good